the stories of fear and survival out of
Michigan State in the aftermath of
Monday's mass shooting there and we know
the names of the victims the students
killed Ariel Anderson was a junior Brian
Frazier a sophomore and Alexandria
Verner also a junior five other students
were hurt and we also know who police
say the gunman was Anthony Duane McRae
officials say he took his own life of
course for many students staff and
faculty this was a terrifying ordeal and
of course the kind that is all too
common for many Americans Roxanna siberi
has been Gathering those stories of fear
and survival in East Lansing for us
Roxanna good morning
good morning here at the MSU Spartan
statue a tribute to the victims is
growing classes here have been postponed
until Monday students are sharing
stories of survival as we're hearing new
details about the gunman
our Spartan Community is reeling today
at an emotional press conference Tuesday
Michigan Governor Gretchen Whitmer
mourned the victims of the deadly
shooting at MSU the school is also her
alma mater another place that is
supposed to be about community and
togetherness Shattered by bullets and
bloodshed
are you ready oh my God just after 8 15
PM Monday an emergency alert instructed
students to run hide or if there was no
other option fight we had went to the
bathroom and like we barricaded the door
with a couch and we just turned all the
lights off that harrowing account was
similarly shared by many as law
enforcement swarmed msu's campus police
say a more than three-hour search for
the shooter ensued before he fatally
shot himself at an off-campus location
this will always be in the back of my
mind 19 year old freshman Ryan Callahan
told us he called his family as he hid
in the library with his girlfriend did
you ever think this could be the last
time I'm speaking to my family it
crossed my mind yeah
um multiple times the students killed in
the shooting are Ariel Anderson who
wanted to be a pediatrician Brian
Frazier the president of his fraternity
and Alexandria Verner an All-State
athlete iconic human being Billy
schellenbarger is the superintendent of
Clawson Public Schools where Werner was
previously a high school student her
heart was huge
her her kindness and and compassion were
Second To None five additional victims
are in critical condition and receiving
Care at ew Sparrow Hospital in Lansing
chief medical officer Denny Martin broke
down as he described the effort to treat
them
didn't get a lot of sleep last night
sorry according to law enforcement the
gunman had no ties to MSU but he did
have a criminal record and was sentenced
to a year of probation in 2019 for
illegally carrying a concealed weapon
without a proper permit he's always
popping off some rounds neighbors say
they regularly heard him firing a weapon
in the backyard of the Lansing home
where he lived with his parents we've
heard the shots and stuff and we'd be
like the heck
here at MSU a vigil will be held tonight
for the victims some students here have
survived other school shootings
including one in Oxford Michigan not far
from here just 15 months ago when four
students were killed
and we hear there was a Survivor from
Sandy Hook there trying to make sense of
the senseless yet again thank you
Roxanna